c'est l'une des deux filières du
laboratoire des archives du cnc certains
films ne passe pas seulement par la
restauration photochimique mais sont
aussi traités de manière numérique et
c'est sur ce scanner que la pellicule va
d'abord passer pour être numérisés la
bobine originale une fois qu'elle a été
restauré mécaniquement lorsqu'on a pu
réparer les coups des co lui ont des
défauts sur le film est chargé sur sept
ce scanner qui va finalement faire une
photo de chaque image du film en très
haute qualité
là c'est ce qu'on appelle un scanner 4k
donc on a plus de 4000 pixels de la
chaussure sur l'image
chaque photo ça allait transformer en
une image informatique donc on va avoir
énormément de suite d'image on peut
avoir un peu plus à 15000 l'image pour
une bobine de 300 m dure à peine dix
minutes numérisation en vue d'une
restauration dite de prestige vous tirez
des défauts comme les poêles ou les
poussières qui ne peuvent être enlevés
autrement le fichier passe alors dans un
logiciel dédié sont des logiciels
vraiment très spécifiques
dont les tous les outils
sont adaptés vraiment aux films anciens
c'est à dire qu'ils vont permettre de
corriger les défauts typiques des films
anciens c'est à dire les poussières le
manque de stabilité et des formations
d'image les rayures et nous notre rôle
c'est effectivement de retirer ses
défauts qui ont pu être causé par le
temps retiré des défauts dus au temps et
n'ont dû à la technique de l'époque un
travail extrêmement minutieux et surtout
très long car ici on travaille image par
image suivant suivre le
le nombre de défauts du film ça peut
être extrêmement long les outils ont
cette possibilité de travailler en
automatique et travaillent 24 heures sur
24 donc ça nous fait gagner du temps
mais le travail de l'opérateur est
nécessaire déjà pour contrôler les
restaurations qui sont faites par les
logiciels est effectivement ensuite
d'aller plus loin pour pour corriger des
défauts qui n'auraient pas pu être
retiré par le logiciel
en plus d'une restauration certains
films bénéficient d'un étalonnage une
opération réalisée pour des
restaurations plus poussée qui
s'effectue dans l'obscurité la plus
totale
l'étalonnage est en fait une
harmonisation colorimétrique des plans
et des séquences pour retrouver une
cohérence visuelle sur la continuité du
film ici par nos travail sur l'admirable
vision un film italien de 1920 dont une
partie des bobines a été retrouvé en
france et l'autre en italie tous les
films ne subissent pas le même degré
d'étalonnage effectivement sur un film
comme l'admirable vision
il ya eu un travail d'étalonnage
très important puisque une fois de plus
le film était dégradée donc il ya eu
tout un travail de recherches afin de
retrouver les couleurs d'origine
voilà tous les films ne sont pas
exploitées de la même manière tout
dépend des éléments que nous avons entre
nos mains
certains éléments
peuvent arriver chez nous en très bon
état et n'ont pas besoin d'un étalonnage
très poussée puisque la copie sera en
bon état contrairement à d'autres films
qui ont vraiment besoin d'un coup de
pinceau 90% du travail d'étalonnage au
cnc se fissure des films de patrimoine
autrement dit les films les plus anciens
une manière de redonner une nouvelle vie
au cinéma d'antan